let's go next to Brian from Ireland who
is also a website member Brian thank you
for being a member on the website
hi David I come through okay you're
coming through beautifully
great
um yeah thanks for having me on again
um pleasure I've been enjoying some of
your videos recently on the uh the CPAC
you know it's kind of a thing I've not
been majorly aware of over the side
Atlantic for
most of its existence so it's quite
horrifying isn't it
it is but I will say a couple of the
videos you put up were
some of the ones I've left the most at
um since joining the channel like the
the Ben Carson one
um where he was you know he was talking
about pretty
uh deep stuff it's on the dead bodies on
the beaches yes and the music place oh
my God oh my God it is it is quite
incredible yeah
it was hilarious and just one more
example was the um
the Kimberly Guilfoyle you know I I was
only listening on the podcast so I
didn't see the video you were talking
about how the room only had 30 people or
whatever but yeah when when they started
cheering it was very clear that there
was barely anyone yes it was it really I
mean they really are parodies of
themselves it's it's stunning stuff
but a question on that then um you know
as I said I don't know a huge amount
about CPAC so sure could you give me an
overview of how influential is it on on
Modern American politics like is it
likely to move the needle in any way in
Trump's favor or will it have very
little impact on the course I don't
think it will impact no because here's
the thing CPAC has increasingly become
a Maga event where people like Mitt
Romney and Paul Ryan and others they
just don't go it's not that they go but
the the needle moves against them they
just don't even attend so CPAC has
become like a self-selected group of
Republicans that are already part of the
the crazy Maga movement so quite frankly
I don't believe CPAC has the the CPAC we
had two weeks ago I think has no impact
on who is going to be the Republican
nominee
okay yeah and I kind of got that Vibe
especially especially with the small
audiences as we're talking about but
yeah yeah it's quite empathetic in a way
at the very least did you get any new
um fun soundboard clips for your
you know I think we added um I don't
know that we got anything from we should
we should look at the top clips and pull
some clips for the soundboard I think
that would be a good idea
yeah and of course it's a lovely new
benefit for members as well absolutely
you get that now do you what do you use
the member sound board for out of
curiosity
well I haven't really used it for
anything functional I've just been kind
of enjoying going through it and uh you
know it's kind of surprising my fiance
at times just putting out uh uh at the
Trump Sur compilation or whatever you
know it's good fun it's not exactly a
productivity tool we can say no I yeah
all right Ryan from Ireland appreciate
hearing from you again
all right there it goes Brian from
Ireland let's take just the quickest of
breaks and get back and talk to more
people on Discord if you're waiting to
talk to me
don't go anywhere because we're coming
right back to Discord in a moment